is a question what should you do when
you see a bicyclist on the road well you
should know this but
people apparently don't you gotta move
over it's the law bianca holmen live on
the move over campaign to protect our
cyclists yaha good morning
hey good morning so it's move over at
least three feet and if possible even to
a different lane so again a lot of
people in clark county know that you
need to give a cyclist room and they may
understand the three-feet rule but
also there's more about that law three
feet is the minimum distance a driver
must give nevada laws says that when
able on a multi-lane road the driver
must merge into the left lane to their
left lane give the cyclist the entire
lane once it's safe and you've passed
the cyclist that's when you can move
back into the original lane when you
don't obey the law cyclists are in
danger
you see your life flash before your eyes
really because it's not that you just
hear it and it's loud it actually sucks
you over and so it actually can be
dangerous when uh you know a car or trap
goes by fast and you can actually swerve
into the lane
so it impacts your ability to to hold
your line and so it's terrifying
keely brooks says that this is an ideal
time to share information about this
campaign because it's getting warm
outside people are looking to get active
and with high gas prices more people are
opting to walk or ride their bike and
also in the next half hour we're going
to talk more about the event that's
happening out here at flamingo and fort
apache on how they're going to try to
help drivers understand this rule and
raise more awareness about this issue
reporting live bianca holman live local
now